let's talk about Imran Khan
the former cricket star turned prime
minister at the center of a political
storm in Pakistan
he was kicked out of office last year is
now facing more than a hundred legal
cases and was briefly arrested in May it
led to huge protests and violence
he's the victim of a conspiracy to force
him out of politics for good what is
happening right now is not because of me
people in Pakistan are really divided
over Imran Khan his supporters see him
as the only hope for their country Iran
has basically become a prophet of change
while his opponents accuse him of
spreading lies and fueling a toxic style
of politics this became a two-way fight
of rhetoric of like Good vs Evil so who
is Imran Han why is he so divisive and
why is politics in Pakistan in such
chaos right now
[Music]
first off let's run through Imran Khan's
backstory
he was born into an upper class family
in Lahore and went to an elite high
school he studied at Oxford University
in England but it was his cricketing
career that made him into a superstar
foreign
1992 he led Pakistan to his first and
only World Cup victory and then retired
from the sport it is easily the greatest
Pakistani cricketer of all time a very
glamorous cricketer too that glamor of
course brought him to the attention of
of high society in London in the early
90s he was hanging out with rock stars
and royalty and married a British
Aristocrat but he was also getting into
charity work and raised money to open a
cancer hospital in Lahore and memory of
his late mother here's a cricketer a
public icon trying to provide free
Cancer Care in a country where this was
not accessible for most people and that
then translated into
a conversation he had about
um the role of corruption improving
governance and then his entry into
politics in 1996 Imran Khan launched his
own political party Pakistan tarike
which means movement for justice he
styled himself as an outsider on an
anti-corruption Mission but his
political career didn't really take off
until 2011. that's when he held two
rallies in Lahore and Karachi tens of
thousands of people showed up he was
promising to bring a new kind of
politics to Pakistan and seven years
later that message helped him get
elected as prime minister inshallah
inshallah
now until Han came on the scene
the politics was dominated by two
parties and two and two families the
Bhutto family which is linked to the PPP
and the Sharif family linked to the pmln
that's the party of the current prime
minister Shahbaz Sharif for years the
two sides have been alternating in power
a pattern that Han was determined to
break to demolish what he called uh the
grip of dynastic politics in Pakistan
he's very popular among young pakistanis
who do not see the Old Guard as being
representative of their Ambitions and
aspirations he's also popular among
middle and upper middle and Elite
classes they are of the view that
Pakistan have been harmed by the
politically corrupt Elite for the too
long and Imran is our hope now there's
another layer in Pakistan's politics
that you need to know about and that's
the military since Pakistan's
independence in 1947 there have been
several military coups and Generals have
ruled directly for 33 years in total but
when there's been a civilian government
the military still plays a big role
behind the scenes
strong influential in meddling them
going on that no government in Pakistan
really gets spawned
without their involvement and it seems
that was also the case for Imran Khan
that the military was pretty influential
in his rise to power this is something
which is acknowledged by the military
leadership of that time people who have
subsequently came out after the
retirement and acknowledged and
confessed that yes we have helped Iran
win and Khan actually sold himself as a
candidate who could work with the
military they were seen as being on the
same page the constant uh struggle and
tension between civil and Military
something that people expected would end
with with harm coming into power but it
didn't here's what happened
so it's 2018 and Imran Khan's just been
elected prime minister it was actually a
pretty contentious election and his
political opponents accused him of fraud
but Han was popular and for a lot of
people it felt like a fresh start
remember his big thing was tackling
corruption something he said was at the
root of most of Pakistan's problems so
he went on a massive anti-corruption
Drive many politicians and government
officials were arrested Hans supporters
approved but his critics said it was
one-sided and that he was only targeting
his political opponents though Han
denies that
busy another criticism was that Han's
approach created a kind of vindictive
and divisive political atmosphere and he
made compromise a bad word you were all
in with Khan or you were anti Khan for
whatever reason that was the
conversation Khan brought with him an
extremely divisive and some would say
hateful style of of of politics much of
that reflected in the language that he
used haranguing his opponents uh and
accusing them of being thieves and crops
[Music]
now the economy was a big issue when Han
was prime minister he inherited a lot of
problems including a major debt crisis
and he had to deal with covid too but
the bottom line was that living
conditions for most pakistanis didn't
improve under Han inflation Sword and
the value of the currency fell as the
economic stress mounted people sort of
began questioning you know what what
this hope and change Mantra was all
about and I think that began to then
erode his popularity overalls your
Democratic you're even right these
things were being impacted qualities
were thrown in jail things like that but
economy was also being impacted and
along with these things in imran's
relationship with military also started
friendship now it's hard to know exactly
how Han's relationship with the military
broke down because this is behind the
scenes kind of stuff but strains
developed after a couple of years with
Hannah's prime minister it seems the
military wasn't happy about the way
things were looking
the economy was in bad shape and on
foreign policy Hans seemed to be going
his own way with a more anti-western
approach there was a reported
disagreement too over the intelligence
Chief who was supposed to leave his job
after three years as per military policy
but Khan wanted him to stay it was kind
of a straw that if not broke the camel's
back it really made things a repairable
from that time onward it's always been a
marriage of unequals every time a
politician or a political party has
Allied itself with Pakistan's military
they always get hurt by it by 2022 it
seemed pretty clear that the military
was pulling their support from Khan by
standing back so the opposition parties
could go after him those parties held a
no-confidence vote in Parliament Khan
lost and Shabbat Sharif replaced him as
prime minister
so what's happened since then well Imran
Khan's been fighting back against what
he says was a conspiracy to remove him
from power we used to claim when he was
being ousted or close to it that there
was an American conspiracy within a few
months
comes tune had changed it has moved from
a conspiracy hatch to Broad to a
conspiracy hatched at home he has also
singled out the serving Army chief
as having some kind of personal grudge
against him he's held huge rallies all
across Pakistan
at one of them he was shot in the leg
and he says it was an assassination
attempt
now Hans been calling for a general
election and under the Constitution that
has to happen by October at the latest
but Han says his opponents are using a
mountain of legal cases more than a
hundred to try to exclude him from
running every other day there's some
sort of case which comes up and a court
appearance they include all sorts of
allegations from corruption to terrorism
even attempt to murder the military
establishment they're too scared for
elections because they're scared I will
win so because of that uh you know
they're doing everything to make sure
that I get out of the race being
convicted on any one of these would lead
to his disqualified Asian which is I
think what they are trying for it all
got pretty dramatic in May when Khan was
arrested in connection with one of the
cases
anger against the arrest of Imran Khan
has turned into violent confrontations a
few gas shells have been fired at this
crowd blocking the main Highway towards
Islamabad these are the protesters and
not in the distance is the police line
and since that violence thousands of
people linked to Han's party have been
detained including senior leaders an
absolutely massive Crackdown undeniably
the state has really come down hard on
Imran and his party
Banner the government is using similar
tactics that he tried to use against
them and has taken things to the next
level to his supporters Imran Khan is
the ultimate political victim and
everything that's happened in the last
year or so has actually boosted his
popularity
[Music]
by all accounts Imran Khan today is uh
Pakistan's most popular politician I
think there is there is agreement that
if elections were to be held tomorrow
um he would win so Imran Khan is as
popular as he's ever been and
disillusionment with the current
government as Shabbat Sharif probably
has something to do with that there's a
full-blown economic crisis Pakistan is
running out of foreign currency and
could soon default on its debts if it
can't secure more loans and millions of
people are still dealing with the
aftermath of last year's floods that
left a third of the country underwater
so while this brutal political fight is
going on there are so many other urgent
problems stacking up
four million people just over a few
months have fallen below the poverty
line and I don't think any segment of
elite Society politically or
institutionally in Pakistan and that
includes the military has an answer to
solving these problems and that's the
real tragedy here complete chaos
happening and it's easy to blame Imran
Khan foreign military for it or this
class or that class and and all of these
allegations have
particular you know partial merits But
ultimately the people who are suffering
are the people of Pakistan the country
as a whole
check out our last explainer on why Arab
countries are cozing up to Syria's
president Bashar al-assad and don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
the next episode of start here
[Music]